breaking news this morning on a story
that we have been following a professor
at Case Western Reserve University in
Cleveland has been arrested over his
alleged financial ties to China this
just days after the FBI sounded the
alarm on China's attempts to steal
current a virus research a professor at
the University of Arkansas was arrested
on similar charges last week and then in
January Harvard's chemistry chief was
charged with failing to disclose that he
too was being paid by the Chinese
Communist Party two weeks ago Senator
Tom cotton told us that the CCP was
trying in many ways to steal medical
data from the United States to try and
come up with a vaccine for kovat 19
before the United States might sit down
with President Trump included this we
discussed IP theft and the pandemics
impact on his relationship with China
and President Xi Jingping secretary
Pompeo said that he has strong evidence
that it did come from the virology lab
we've been reporting this every Sunday
by the way from early on you also said
that you saw evidence can you tell us
anything about the intelligence no but
we have a lot of information and it's
not good but you know the worst of all
whether it came from the lab or came
from the batch circuit it all came from
China and they should have stopped it
they could have stopped it at that
source I call it the source right there
the decision to allow it to escape its
borders I don't know if they made the
decision but it got out of control I
think more likely it got out of control
Senator John said that they didn't want
the Chinese economy to contract 20% and
the rest of the world to contract 2% so
we were beating them very badly before
this we were beating them between the
tariffs and other things we were doing
and we were going up and they were
having a very bad year they were having
the worst year they've had in 56 years
on the street and they work well and
even beyond that and we were really
doing well and that is a theory but
here's what I know for sure they didn't
allow this whole thing they didn't allow
people to go into China but they did
allow them to go out to the world
including the United States
that's why Europe is a mess that's why
look at look at these countries right
just having a hard time everybody's
absolutely will it get worse for those
countries do you think yeah it's for
some of them some have just started the
process we're getting toward the end of
the process you know so they downplayed
the the disease they downplayed the
virus at the same time they're allowing
international travel five million people
leaving Wuhan going to Italy going to
the United States then they start
cornering the market on protective
equipment even though China is already
the the largest producer that's not the
big thing look the big thing is they
should have never let this happen
so I make a great trade deal and now I
say it just doesn't feel the same to me
the ink was barely dry and the plague
came over and it doesn't feel the same
to me I think I got it they're not gonna
buy the 250 billion are they they will
buy 250 250 billion they said somewhere
I see they'd like to renegotiate the
deal we're not gonna renegotiate look
I'm not happy about anything having to
do with that particular subject right
now have you spoken to Gigi Peng
I have a very good relationship but I
just right now I don't want to speak to
because you know senator cotton was
saying maybe we should be limiting the
amount of visas that we give to students
who want to study things like many
things and AI there are many things we
could do we could do things we could cut
off the whole relationship now if you
did what would happen you'd say 500
billion dollars if you cut off the whole
relationship look at what point does it
and I said this for years I said it with
other countries also you know China's
not the only country ripping us off at
NATO where we defend Europe for nothing
by the way essentially nothing I was
able to get them to pay hundreds of
billions of dollars more you know my
biggest fan of the world secretary
Stoltenberg has said that to me I'm
actually he's been there a long time he
said nobody's ever gotten you know we
were paying more and more they were
paying less you have to see the chart
of what they pay so we are defending
Europe and then they're taking advantage
of us on trade it's all one way and it
was all turning and it is all turning
around and you put back we've been
proven to be right yeah I pulled back
the money from the thrift fund they
wanted to put 10% of the thrift fund
into MSCI index companies will you go
one step further and force that Chinese
companies have to follow accounting
rules if they want to be listed on the
new york stock at that very strongly but
but on the thrift fund you know it's run
by the Obama appointments right and we
said you got to do this and we're going
to find out whether or not they going to
do it very soon and if they're not we're
gonna replace them very quickly yeah we
are looking at your second part of your
question we're looking at that because
Chinese companies like an Alibaba any
Chinese company they're listed on the
New York Stock Exchange they don't have
to report their earnings the way of an
American company does amazing but here's
the problem with that you know look I
hate to say it but let's say we do that
right so what are they gonna do they're
gonna move their listing to London or
someplace else you see let's say you
want to get tough and you're gonna do
you know everyone everyone wants to be a
tough guy look I'm the toughest guy but
what happens is so we say you're gonna
do this and you're gonna follow the
rules of the New York Stock Exchange or
Nasdaq what do they do they say okay
we'll move to London or we'll go to Hong
Kong